I absolutely love love Oprah everyone
loves it everyone loves over so you know
I went to South Africa and then I moved
to Germany and then she had this Vision
tour just before we took pictures she's
like I don't want to hear your life
story
that's it so we just took the picture
and I was so frightened you can see my
head I I was like moving away because
does she say I don't want to hear your
love story to everybody yes I mean
imagine you're Oprah Winfrey how many
stores would you hear like everybody
wants to tell you how they survived so
so I could understand even then I
thought oh she taught me a lesson again
boundaries you know time you don't get
the time back I fully understood that I
do it all the time now
it doesn't matter I don't want to hear
the story
not interested